looking for some cooking inspiration
we've got you covered
chef jeff from smith's is sharing the
recipe from parmesan and lemon roasted
asparagus take a look
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smiths okay today i'm going to show you
how to
make a delicious side dish for any
family gathering or dinner
this is going to be roasted asparagus
with parmesan and lemon and it's super
delicious and
super easy and i love when asparagus is
in season because
it's cheap and i just love to roast it
in fact i think that's probably the best
way to do asparagus is to roast either
that or put it on the grill or the two
best ways
okay so first thing with asparagus is
asparagus has a little woody end
on one on the bottom side that's not
edible you could try and chew on it but
it's just no good
the best and probably the the way you
should be doing this is just by snapping
it off
and then you know and do this with each
one but i don't i don't
ever have patience for that so i snap
one of them and then put it on the
others for a guide and just cut the
other ones at that point
that just kind of makes it a little bit
easier to to kind of gauge that but if
you want to go and snap each one
by all means do it but for me i'll just
cut
okay so my oven is preheating to 425 so
it's a hot oven
and get these on my sheet pan here with
parchment paper
and then i'm going to take some olive
oil and just kind of lightly go over it
then i'm going to take some salt and
pepper put over the top
a little bit of garlic powder
okay and then i'm just gonna mix it just
like so with my hands
just so it evenly coats it all and kind
of spread it out
and then you could just throw it in the
oven like this and it'd be perfectly
fine but
let's uh let's doctor it up a little bit
let's make it delicious so i'm going to
take some parmesan cheese and sprinkle
over the top
just like so over the entire thing
a little more why not and then i'm going
to take some lemons
and just kind of take across the middle
and this is just an optional step this
is just for presentation purposes
i just like the way it looks when it
comes out of the oven like this
and then i'm going to take the other
half of so that's a half of a lemon then
i'm going to go ahead and squeeze the
other half
just on top just like that
okay these are ready for the oven and so
when you roast when you roast asparagus
it just gets this texture and then
the tops of them get all roasted and
toasty brown and everything about it is
just delicious
don't ever boil your or steam your
asparagus that's the most boring way
if you like it that way fine but i'm
just telling you it kicks it up 10
notches when you do it this way
let's get this in the oven and i have
one that's in there already
if it's done it probably goes for about
15 minutes i would say
and then it comes out just looking
spectacular
and i would say that i would just serve
it just like this i don't even want to
try to take it off and put it on a
platter
or anything like that just because i
love the way that it looks
and it's just so springy and perfect for
really any time of year as long as your
asparagus are in season
go ahead and get it you can find all of
these things at your
local smiths of course in the produce
section you're always going to find
asparagus and lemons
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we'll see you all next
time bye-bye
if you want that recipe and ingredients
you can visit smithsfoodanddrug.com
and we